la frontera está cerrada a la defensiva
y acusada de provocar la afluencia de
miles de emigrantes la administración de
joe biden estuvo este domingo en todos
los frentes tratando de tranquilizar a
la gente sobre su capacidad para manejar
la primera gran crisis de su presidencia
estamos en el proceso de hacerlo ahora
incluso asegurándonos de restablecer lo
que existía antes que era que podían
quedarse en su casa y presentar su caso
desde su país de origen
byd en que anunció que viajará en algún
momento a la frontera se ha enfrentado a
las críticas de los republicanos por su
gestión el gobierno de bailén ha tenido
problemas para albergar al creciente
número de menores no acompañados que
viajan solos desde centroamérica son más
de 14.000 niños niñas y adolescentes que
están en custodia por parte de las
autoridades estadounidenses
específicamente bajo el cuidado del
departamento de salud y servicios
humanos y otros por la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza
alejandro mayorkas secretario de
seguridad nacional reconoció que se
esperaba una afluencia histórica de
migrantes la mayor en 20 años en la
frontera sur
sin embargo llamó de los migrantes
centroamericanos a no venir por ahora lo
que el presidente se ha comprometido y
lo que yo me comprometo y ejecutó es
asegurar que tenemos un sistema de
inmigración que funciona y que la
migración a nuestro país es segura
ordenada y humana en gmail ante el
anuncio de bailén de ir a la frontera el
ex presidente donde el templo acusó de
haber creado un desastre nacional y
reivindicó su legado afirmando que
entregó al gobierno de byd en la
frontera más segura de la historia e
instó a reanudar la construcción del
muro en la frontera con méxico